good morning everyone good morning
millenium happy Wednesday it is an
unfunny Wednesday I've never felt worse
and I feel like I've been hit by a bus
and I can't identify why no you want to
know what it is I feel like I'm like so
hungover and I literally have not I said
without home for days I was feeling
great I woke up sprightly AAF did my
makeup feeling good
I'd like ten extra minutes so I sat down
on the couch something happened to me on
my couch look I feel like I got some
anthrax is that it are these the
symptoms of anthrax fatigue yes
general malaise fatigue is a side effect
of like everything being alive yeah I
feel fatigue in everyday life look at
every moment of every day I feel
comfortable using fatigue jargon in
everyday life like seriously I'm
fatigued AF and fatigue is the perfect
word to describe how you're feeling when
feeling fatigued no totally maybe you
need um actually you might need
electrolytes because you're dieting ah
that's what happens that you feel just
want to say I'm not dieting can't use
that word anymore did you know that I've
heard that you can't use it so I put it
on my Instagram and it was a joke like I
wasn't because I obviously don't really
die you are dieting you know just eating
less that's a diet sure and I use the D
word and literally people were telling
you that I have eating disorders and
that I'm promoting eating disorder
mentality to things in case I you know
misspoke I do not promote eating
disorders I think they're very bad as
most rational people - second of all I
know I look very thin but I also do not
have anything disorder which common
misconception I get that oh good like
seriously like I didn't know that
weren't I it was such a trigger for
people I lost a lot of followers for
making one joke that used the D word
that's out of control you don't want
those followers anyway because it's oh
it'll always be something that's true
you can't win any of them no it was so
crazy like I think I literally would
have gotten better bat like less
backlash if I used like the C word wow I
just don't understand what's wrong with
going on a diet like how if how diet
automatically means disordered eating
like
sometimes it's a good way and you need
to lose weight are you saying that we
should just wait whatever we want also
the best part about this whole thing was
people weren't yeah I mean that I'm like
promoting such negative body image and
that I like that I'm so unhealthy I
should just lose weight well that's why
I'm on a diet like it was so roundabout
stupid like these people are morons it
was so funny well they can't keep their
like their arguments to drink great
because they keep contradicting
themselves like because they're so
caught up they keep telling me that I'm
like I'm unhealthy and I should lose
weight but then if I use the D word I'm
promoting an eating disorder so how can
I need to lose weight but also have an
eating disorder no how can you just go
on a diet and it just not be an eating
disorder wait how can you just want to
help people have been doing it for
centuries so I think you're gonna be
fine
look how many I'll let you know if it
starts to get a little crazy I know I'm
the border of like almost being like
needing to be worried about but I'm good
for right now you are gonna long story
you should have electrolytes what do I
drink them you put like I have these
packets you put in a bottle of water
shake it up no calories and it'll just
help you get your [ __ ] together
I really don't feel like like my arms
why 700 pounds right now I can't become
up same awesome because like I'm like
the districted yeah but and also because
I did my fifth instil I post session
yesterday so I'm wearing my girdle under
my jeans which already don't fit me oh
that's that I can't breathe that's tough
however the good news is that we really
do have some good stories today of
course because this is the most
well-rounded we just just say that it
was a joke but now we truly are and
well-rounded morning show and morning
speaking of morning shows oh my god you
guys literally like I can't do you need
someone to explain for you
I got bud I got bombarded with like a
bunch of messages on my Instagram and in
the toaster Facebook group that they
were talking about Carl has a job on the
view and I'm like great cuz when our
whole thing went down the view had asked
us to come on and like I'm so afraid of
the view even when I'm not in trouble
that when I am in trouble like I'll stay
away but I liked I like Megan McCain I
think she's really good like Bravo ties
yeah and she's always not much up inside
and she has really good takes on Bravo
stuff and she got into the fight with
Teddy Mellencamp and they were talking
they were recapping the Bachelorette on
the view which is just that in itself
it's like kind of funny I don't know why
like Joy Behar talking about the view
about the Bachelorette is like stupid
but I think the views on ABC Oh synergy
synergy integration and they were
talking about the Virgin thing with
Colton and I had done what I thought to
be some epic Instagram stories and I
guess Megan McCain thought the same and
I knew she found me and surround me like
I'm DM back and forth and she was like
mentioned girl with no job interim
stories and she quoted me on this year
yeah I got to download the clip and put
on my Instagram that's hard to do I
don't know how to do it the toasters can
do it the toasters can do any anything I
like I'm getting so toaster reliance and
I'm like I couldn't even make a graphic
for me like you know I was just like I
didn't do it like what's a good app to
put a video on the background like a
grandma trying to use the microwave
speaking of which someone put that clip
in the toasters last night the token
clip do you brush like this morning very
sad you guys I was really like for the
past like a week trying to find a name
of someone like to stock on Instagram
and like I didn't know the person's name
and like I was really considering
putting it in the TI a like the three
bits of information that I knew but if
it ever got back to this person that I
was looking for this person like it
would be mortifying but you don't even
know the person that you're looking for
yeah but I know the ties like I can't
give too much information because I
don't wanna give it away but I was on a
major stock and I like I enlisted
Olivia's help because she is like insane
and even she could have find it I'm like
this is a job for the TI a-and do you
ever find it I did find it on my own and
it was very rewarding that's nice not
only do we have the Fast Five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your mo morning
toast I was gonna make a joke moaning
but we have Raven gates from bachelor
master in Paradise joining us later and
I'm so excited because Raven of one half
of Radin ribbon and Adam right and she
is one of my favorite people to ever
come off of bachelor both like
personally and some team you know it's
hard sometimes translated on TV and then
you meet them you're like mad sometimes
you don't love someone on TV but you
need them oh my god and I loved her on
TV and I loved her in person and I loved
her Instagram and I'm so excited same so
make sure you got your questions to her
but I think we've got this one
you know we've definitely oh this one
covered and we got some really good
questions on our Instagram yeah at the
morning shows make sure you're following
us make sure you're following us or
premium content left right and center
before anyone else posts it including
but not limited to other people who
steal from us like I used to when we
first started the show
and we like had all these terms and like
we were posting things on internment
like people were posting similar things
I would like oh every one's copying us
but then I was like being paranoid I'm
like I'm just I'm sensitive because like
this is my baby and like we worked so
hard on the show and if anyone posts or
does anything remotely similar like I
automatically think it's copy and I'm
probably just being dramatic but I have
since learned that I'm not being
dramatic and literally everyone copy
says Oh agree but I do I think it's a
good this is a good time to make
something clear there are some things
that we say that people are straight-up
copying us there are some things that we
say that we did not invent no so like
shook to the core wait a minute we did
not invent that so we just me me me me
in the mainstream no it was mainstream
others say it all the damn time but
don't worry about us when you see shucks
to the court that's fair game here for
it we did not amend that what else
protected all costs we did in men just
as for we did invent oh it is for the
Amanda The Amanda Show
that's the Orion spur HJ anyone I'll say
that we totally look at her stupid
gavels that we've had literally for over
a year the fact that justice has become
such a regular part of everyday life for
every millennial and it is not credited
back to us is crazy it's crazy and
protect at all costs what the [ __ ] is
going on and by the way Chris Hemsworth
does not need to be protected he's he
could protect himself if he can't
protect in the South no one can know by
the way did you see the spot hurry like
ten minute documentary I made some ramps
I did and the opening was amazing and
then when they started talking to the
guy in the town who was like everyone
here knows everyone's name like it's
really such a small town like shits
Creek vibes and then I got a little
bored you know I thought it was so sweet
like the thing is it's like I don't
think Mason Ramsay is like bursting with
personality like he's just a quiet shy
kid who was like a very talented voice
so they were like leaning on the people
in the town and like the Walmart to like
be characters in this film and his
grandparents also are just very blah
like they don't have like raging
personalities but they're just such a
nice family egg he deserves everything
that is happening to him and so to his
grandparents and I just I'm so glad that
they'll never have to like worry again a
day in their life I'm just curious
and I had a feeling they weren't gonna
speak on it and they didn't really speak
on his parents yeah but we know it
happened yes sort of sort of well I
guess his parent oh that's what
so his grandparents have raised him and
they've done an excellent job they
deserve all of the riches of his success
he's so cute he's so cute and he's
getting cuter and did you see the video
that he posted of him jamming out with
some six-year-olds and yes one of his
new songs it's so good him hanging out
with like that crew he's fine
so I'm Brent so I'm brand he's
protecting you guys and I'm so excited
for his EP he's such a [ __ ] cutie
apparently there's breaking news a cardi
B had her baby but I don't know if
that's true I saw it in the toasters
yesterday that she did yeah that someone
who works at a hospital in Atlanta told
their friend that cardi B was giving her
the name is culture that's just what the
toasters are saying honestly usually
when the toasters say it it's true okay
a la Halley and Justin but we can't
report it as official news until someone
realized last Stormies Kylie's baby name
yeah that was crazy
that was crazy except number the time
that someone meet up that kind of is
bright that's what I was gonna say so
this feels like deja and literally the
toasters made it on the Daily Mail
because they started a rumor that Kylie
was in labor at cedars-sinai and they
literally had like a picture like a
snapchat of the hospital and it just
looked so real and it took the world by
storm cuz everyone was waiting for Kylie
there all by swimming and everyone was
waiting for Kylie she still hadn't even
confirmed the pregnancy and it literally
this rumored that they made up and kept
on the daily now cardi B posted on her
Instagram so it is confirmed gritty and
I just want to say I saw it in the
toasters yesterday love you girls and
boys fantastic it's real news it's real
news and toasters we're right on this
one as they always are okay who's ready
to jump in to the Fast Five stories you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast if
you're eating toast
who is shooting us who is she faint who
has two thumbs it is ready to hear the
fast five stories this girl first up you
guys this is incredible Kylie Jenner 20
don't forget it
lands on the cover of Forbes as she's
poised to become the youngest self-made
billionaire as she banks over 900
million dollars thanks to her cosmetic
range in literally like two and a half
years that is [ __ ] crazy so she's
worth nine hundred million right now
she'll probably cross 1 billion in a
month or two yeah she's on the cover of
Forbes she looks bomb as [ __ ] and
businesswoman as how she's eating the
businesswoman special no down no she
invented them a businessman special I
have two things to say what's so
impressive about this whole thing
what
impressive is and this is what the
Forbes article says is that not only is
it very rare that a 20 year old starts a
billion dollar company but it's even
more rare that she owns a hundred
percent of it so Kylie didn't have any
investors anytime she like wanted to
invest in like product she put her own
money up yes makeups are cheap and she
started out probably like a hundred
thousand lip kits but she never had to
get money from anyone because she was so
rich before yeah and because I think was
probably a small investment that she
needed right and then she just kept
reinvesting in her own business
can you imagine is she wealthier than
Kim yes that's crazy
she was wealthier than Kim I think a
year ago when it Kylie cosmetics hit
that half a million mark that's crazy
Kim works so hard I know and for so long
so Kylie could be born a couple years
later like stumble into a billion dollar
business and I'm happy for Kylie I'm
happy for Kim 90 and I don't think that
there's animosity in a certain point
like we're all flying private like we're
all okay yeah but like Kim works so hard
like she was doing like appearances at
see her junior I can't Karl's doing
yours actually cool like yes but it's a
lot of work Sears I'm episode where she
is you the burger like a hundred times
oh yeah oh my god that just that hurts
me a little but now I'm gonna say one
controversial thing about this cover I
do not like her spiky hair coming out of
her bun in the back okay and I think her
face looks a little wrinkly that's all
I'm gonna say
okay and I'm gonna and I'm gonna go up
against you because I actually did like
the spiky hair coming out in the back
because honestly any time you do a low
bun like you can't avoid the spikes and
she's making this bike school appreciate
it I think her face looks good she looks
very serious and I also want to say you
guys I know that Kylie said that she
removed all of her lip fillers but she
did not she removed most of her lip
fillers but she still has bigger lips
and she was born with well I believe
that this cover was shot before
discovered just in general like his
pictures that she's been posting with
Stas like she looks amazing her lips
look more natural but she had no lips to
begin with so that's where she'd be at
that's true I guess unless she like just
grew up and also that's what auntie said
oh yeah and he said she didn't remove
out whatever she looks so good like
because she put up her own Instagram
pictures and you can really never trust
someone's own Instagram pictures I mean
if you looked at my Instagram you think
that I let her weighed like 90 pounds
but I'm not promoting a name designer
but so she got tagged in some like Getty
photos and those are the ones I posted
on our morning shows Instagram because
that's even more fascinating to me and
she
looked incredible yeah body face on
point I'm just so happy for her like she
is living the life of Riley and she's
not even 21 I know it's just like she
better have the craziest birthday party
ever
now this is the thing I feel like it's
just a little ok she's 20 she's already
a mom she's already a businesswoman
she's already been on a cover of every
like she's already float like she
doesn't have anything left to accomplish
hailey mean yes and I would agree with
that but I think that that's why her
being a mom like made so much sense yes
now her accomplishment is her child
raising her child will always be
something that she has to do 18 years
and like that will fulfill her in ways
like yes she has every car everything
she ever wanted all the money that
she'll ever need but like this child
will give her more purpose that's know
that's right like her being a mom she
makes when she put out that video like
everything made sense even though
everyone when they were doing interviews
of all people at her baby shower they
were like Kylie's always wanted to be a
mom like I didn't get that but from
Kylie at all and like how can you want
to be a mom so bad wouldn't like 16 you
know right but I do get it I'm just like
she's being she's so blocked beyond her
years like she's lived the life of a 60
year old like businessman you know so I
get the kid thing it definitely makes
sense that she's a mom but I just don't
know it's like too young to have done so
much but that's just kind of Jenner and
that's why she's worth she's the
youngest self-made billionaire yeah you
gotta be young and you know what Margaux
wanted to be a mom since she was younger
yeah we used to ask her what she wanted
to be when she grew up and she said a
mom and a cheerleader yeah purple time
sure with her very true what a sweet
answer I'm just so curious about Kylie's
love life because I read the blinds but
then her and Travis like make one
appearance like a month
look do they live together but they have
a kid but I don't think Travis lives in
her house I don't know Jordan lives in
her house she has some weird [ __ ]
she definitely has weird [ __ ] and I
don't know how like monogamous her and
Travis are like not that someone's
stepping out on the other I just don't
know like what their situation is but I
feel like she whatever it is it's like
she's cool with it
you know maybe she has some other men in
her life who knows yeah she can she's
the youngest self-made billionaire no
she's about to become a billionaire
father I feel like it's jinx because the
company's now valued at 800 million and
yes it'll
probably close crossover a billion but
to put on the cover of magazine before
it happens it's crazy that is crazy but
her summer collection comes out on
Friday and it looks like one of the best
she's had in a while and I'm pretty sure
that'll be the thing well she is gonna
be a billionaire hopefully a good knock
on wood before Mark Zuckerberg was he
was a twenty three loser god Mark
Zuckerberg how old are ya I mean I was
the first self-made oh my god I'm 24 was
about to say 23 I was the first
self-made 100 air at $2,300 maybe
account and you're the first ever see
that at they write it was really
impressive that's what people were
saying I mean I didn't read the press
cuz like it was a lot for me but
basically they were saying it's like I
was so ahead of my time my savings
account yeah I read that and it was all
positive news yeah all positive
this year has only been full of good
positive news for me okay anyways
congratulations to Kylie and I'm so
excited to see what's next for her and
now that I think about it I need to
refresh my makeup
starring Kylie and I need to figure out
how to put on eye shadow like yeah
that's my goal oh I forgot my goal is
take an eyeshadow class take a cooking
class driver's ed driver's ed my goal is
to figure out how to get skin that isn't
drying pili even by doing all the right
things like I've used a night cream
that's very creamy I use a creamy face
wash and I drink a lot of water recently
like my face is still so dry why maybe
your face washes is drying well I got a
new one because when I sensational so I
was like why is my skin so jar she gave
me a whole new regimen if you get it's
not good to get oil free makeup face
product says you need the oil and which
is just oil free anything so I have it's
a cream based face wash and a very
creamy night cream and I'm putting it on
like 100 times and I just I can't get my
skin to to stop being so dry I don't
know what about if you put like Mara
crude oil in your foundation so you're
familiar well even then before I put on
my first I don't even wear foundation
but even before I put on Tarte drink of
water I put on charging of water I put
on a very hydrating primer I put on a
brightening like I put on a million
things on my face before my actual
makeup it's a problem no cuz then if I
didn't it would be like crusty makeup
what's worse than cross Omega
nothing truly nothing I'd rather see you
in no makeup and then you're like brave
what are your thoughts on k'kaw makeup I
don't use it I would I want to I mean
first of all just based on all of her
marketing branding and the products that
she's making they're literally for
everyone except for me and my coloring
yeah so I'll respect so they take the
back seat on this and I haven't heard
great things about a lot I feel like
it's very hit-or-miss
and I'm happy with the Kylie makeup I
feel like if I saw something of Kim's
that I had to have I would have it the
only thing I thought I might need is the
contour kit which got horrible reviews
and I don't really use contour sticks
anymore but when I got Kim's I used them
they were fine I just feel like Kylie's
got the makeup thing covered and they
say that they don't compete I don't
believe that but I think Kim should
really stick with the fragrances because
I think that's so Kim that's like how
she started her business that's how she
makes so much money and fragrances are
so lucrative and like maybe some
skincare and like some body oils like I
just think she need not be making the
same things as Pilar inking cuz it's the
lesser version and like the lipstick
color said she's making it's like
they're not colors they're all nudes
they're the same nudes and they're
yellowy and they make your teeth look
yellow and like Kylie is really changing
the game of lip colors right and what
Kylie does like she makes lip colors and
foundations and concealers like from
every for every skin tone like it's
super inclusive so does Kim except for
the little people and the lipsticks too
like that's a very limited amount of
people who can wear that nude yeah I
think the only person is Kim Kardashian
right she's maybe but I actually I've
heard that her baking powder is really
good yeah but I like my making like I
didn't wasn't looking for making matter
I'm not I don't love my baking powder I
don't know well maybe I'll give it
another shot yeah like it's expensive
and here's the thing about perfume I
agree like that's she's made so much
money from it but it is so wild to me
that she sells hundreds of millions of
units of both Moya with no one ever
having smelled it like that's [ __ ]
crazy no that's a racket that's the
world we live in and I decided for him
she's selling water yeah with like a
little flower in it that's [ __ ] crazy
no and great for her but I don't know
how you guys buy it without smelling it
yeah no it's just like honestly
Kim has made so many people around her
like obsessed with makeup and like
famous from makeup like makeup
mário like livery sells out arenas like
he is rolling in it I think if like a
regular person wanted to have megabyte
Mario do their makeup they would have to
pay him like 30 grand just for the night
he is rolling and it Kylie is rolling in
it and like Kim like just kind of got
left behind do you know any mean but she
didn't cuz she's more than fine and I
feel like she's more than fine I think
then the business perspective yeah but
also like she didn't get left behind
because she's in the thick of it it's
just not sticking and it's like she even
did that show glam masters and then did
a collaboration with the person who won
and so many people said that like they
did some creamy eyeshadow stick and they
were like that is not what that makeup
artist would've ever got it and it's
like just not everything as being
thought through and it I feel like Kylie
made makeup because she loved it and she
she was wearing all these colors and she
just wanted and she was selling out Mac
around the world Kim made makeup to make
money know what to make makeup that's
true you know and you can't go into it
like that it's like trying to it's like
joining Instagram to be an influencer
we're not gonna just have to love making
comments a hat like have the knack for
it that is a great analysis thank you I
think we should move on but with that
said Kim is doing just fine yeah and I
still don't and I bought Kanye merch and
don't make me choose between the two and
I'm so like cool now you know well when
it came out I was like I just happened
to be like on Twitter when Kanye tweeted
it was like sure it looks a bit like
wasn't that expensive it was really cool
that Wyoming stuff I'm like that Kim was
back yeah and I was like okay I want to
be him so I bought one and then I was
like been like would it like be so
jealous and steal it so I bought that
one too and they can literally I never
heard from Kanye again and a month later
I just got randomly like had forgotten
about it and got an email it's on the
way like okay and it's cute yeah very
exciting okay next story photographer
ban from vogue got the invite to Anna
Wintour's daughter's wedding this story
is actually really crazy I know I do
clash with me too at B Schafer's wedding
we're told that's a great opener yet as
oil Coleman at page six according to a
guest superstar photographer Bruce Weber
was invited to the affair at the mother
of the bride Anna Wintour sprawling
estate even though she publicly
announced in January that her company
Conde Nast was blacklisting him after he
was accused of sexual misconduct by more
than a dozen people but we're told
Webber was seen mingling with the other
guests celebrating the marriage of
Schaffer to Francesco Carr Zini the son
of late Vogue Italia editor in
chief oh that's so funny yeah as well as
being close to Wintour Weber also had a
long relationship with both Sozzani who
passed away in 2000 and the groom who
was also a photographer in January the
New York Times reported that 15 male
models who worked with Webber Fame for
his photography for Vogue Calvin Klein
and Abercrombie and Fitch
Wow one of these things is not like the
other among others described a pattern
of what they said was unnecessary nudity
and coercive sexual behavior often
during photoshoots I just feel like
first of all I'm obsessed with her
daughter Beatrice like I found her
Instagram a couple months ago at the Met
Gala and I just like have been obsessed
with like what a lovely life to be born
into like I would take it in a heartbeat
like just rich and well-known and she's
beautiful like what a life and now she's
marrying like another vogue heir like
they're just gonna have a great life I'm
really happy for them but like Anna
Wintour is like consistently on the
wrong side of history I feel like we are
always talking about like her and Marcus
not like I'm sorry Marchesa is a sham
like what they like no one should ever
wear Marquesa again and like then doing
that vogue thing trying to bring my case
I like back into the fold like sorry no
they were literally blackmailing people
into wearing their dresses so Harvey
could like touch her vagina eyes and now
again with Bruce Weber like Anna
Wintour's always and like no one ever
comes for Anna Wintour but you know what
I'm here the reckoning is here
very exciting also we reported a while
back that she was gonna be out at Vogue
after her daughter's wedding this
summer's know the clock is ticking is
that true or not oh so I just want to
say one thing like and it might be
controversial you know Anna delivers oh
yeah I follow her and in scrims she is I
think Vogue Spain Vogue France something
high up there and she is so glamorous
like her outfits are epic she throws
this great gala every year she's always
taking risks she's always getting
photographed like I should say I've
literally never seen Anna Wintour in a
dress that I would ever even think about
wearing no she definitely has good style
and and I like that she's very
consistent and it's all up here you know
like I'm sorry you're supposed to be a
creative person you don't work lets you
look in a magazine professional I agree
like I think I understood dressing
they're always ugly oh I disagree
always and what's with that hair take
off your sunglasses [ __ ] we're inside
I'm sorry I'm just not here for Anna
Wintour at all no I'm not here for her
at all either but like I understand what
she's been doing up until this point but
it's time
New Era to be yesterday right maybe she
should go take care of her love child
that empty told us about who lives in
another country
absolutely she's like always missing
mark Lagarde here's the best example of
what why Anna Wintour should have been
fired years ago just take one look at
Kim Kardashian on the cover of Vogue I
can't believe she's only been on the
cover of Vogue once and it's that
horrendous picture horrendous first of
all she looked unhappy her makeup is
terrible
her body is like being smothered in this
huge parachute she looks terrible like
that
I can't believe Kim has to hang that in
her house like she's fun if you like
pretend to be shouting right like so
classy because she really was like oh my
god I love it so much yeah you know she
did not know cuz she's so obsessed with
the way that she looks right she should
be it's her whole business like she even
doesn't like how she looks when she
looks amazing
right let alone when she looks like she
did on the cover of Vogue so I just I
can't believe that like that's the one
thing we got from Kim Kardashian on
Vogue and that's when Anna Wintour it
was fairly obvious she's not in tune
with what's necessary and she should
have been fired years ago
agreed and bring back him on vogue bring
back our kitten that's where Kim should
be totally revamping her vote cover no
but like literally if you open up a
magazine like it's so crazy how like Kim
influences everything like from makeup
to hair to style like and the fact that
she doesn't like have a column or
something like she should just be in
vogue all the time the Kim influences
everything in the way that people dress
it's like every time she steps out it's
like okay that was a weird voice six
months later everyone's wearing it and
you forget that she was the one who took
the chance I choose loose I choose biker
shorts a she's wearing biker shorts now
my gir shorts are gonna be huge in a
month mica shirts are already like
people are like people in the stylish
jeans like where can I get a pair of
shorts and you know what's so crazy is
that all of that is influenced by Kanye
because the easy
shorts the EZ lucite heels like they're
so influential and I feel like they get
so much [ __ ] and like Anna Wintour like
if you open up a bow it's like I see Kim
everywhere yeah with the lips and like
I've seen even in her pregnancy with
Saint when she only wore bodycon dresses
that went below the knee a new look I'm
kimonos kimono is what every Saad is
wearing now kami of that is the best if
you have like a good baby bump that is
the best pregnancy and then she even
wore it before she got pregnant and
after she got pregnant and every that's
the go-to look now for business women
everywhere the only thing I'm not
agreeing with a hundred percent on her
style is this super long hair I don't
think it's cute I don't think it's cute
either and it's also like not realistic
and everyone walks around like that like
that is sturdy yeah um but you know what
she's taking a chance she's making a
statement and it's very post Paris yes
you know minimalist she's allowed to do
whatever she could do whatever she wants
she never got a ring which I thought was
so crazy she just wears like a wedding
band that is crazy I don't know I just
think I love her and it's crazy I was
watching an old episode of Kardashians
like what they used to wear before like
sadi as hell like she ripped jeans with
like blazer wear or like wouldn't look
literally tops where their tits were
flowing out and that just would never
fly now no I mean if you watched he's in
one of the Kardashians and they're just
laying around their house and like jeans
and wife beater that's a whole nother
level like when she was dating like Kris
Humphries like that level where they'd
be a really big star yeah she was always
very mini-dress but they didn't even
know what was to come
yeah she was like she dress like she
shopped it like Siri yeah me like that
that's so true how much she was always
wearing Blazers that's so true oh and I
bony yeah or like her long yeah she had
a great hair like trademark yeah and
even her makeup was different but I'm
still good never wear that makeup now
that's so true it's just really crazy
and you know what's so great about them
is that they've evolved like that in
2007 like that was the style right on
top of it and now it's 2018 and they're
at the top of it this is the style in
there at the top of it totally about the
guy I know and we keep talking about how
we have so many interests other than
like social media in the car actually
no no but here's now we're gonna get
into our story that it's just a little
bit you know different and it'll keep
you in tune with what you need to know
okay actually one more thing cuz I was
gonna say that ranch that they grew up
in like that one short house I thought
they should really just own it just for
like make it a museum
yeah something but someone put a clip in
the toasters of their episode of cribs
and like Kim was the host and she was
like I love to bake and she's like here
I just baked these and she shows she has
these three jars of cookies and whatever
and in one of the jars is those cookies
with the frosting that are the front of
every grocery store that are
unbelievable
and she claimed to have baked them well
you know what maybe she did that's how
she did she didn't and and good for her
for knowing that those cookies are
what's good because apparently there's
controversy around them because some
people think they're discussing and
you're disgusting if you think those
cookies are disgusting
I can't believe that there's even a
single person on this earth who just not
that they don't like them that they
think they're disgusting honestly that's
like what everyone thinks when we were
in where were we just when we were in
Utah we had got a bunch of snacks I mean
it gotten like a big platter of those
[ __ ] ease and they were gone in like a
week there's no like a day they're so
good
okay are you ready for this next story
Southwest Airlines says it will stop
serving peanuts pretzels or peanuts
passengers on Southwest Airlines will no
longer have to decide after the carrier
announced that it has plans to stop
serving peanuts to protect people who
are allergic to them quote peanuts will
forever be part of Southwest history and
DNA the company sent me an email it's a
weird thing to say however to ensure the
best onboard experience for everyone
especially for customers with peanut
related allergies we've made the
difficult decision to discontinue
serving peanuts on all flights beginning
August 1st so honestly that seems like a
very rational thing I failed two sides
of it now explain it's very rational
like there are people who literally cut
like touch it and they'll die like smell
it it's like a weapon like and I totally
agree like it shouldn't be allowed but
there's a part of me like when I was
growing up there was maybe two or three
things I like to eat and only like one
of them was peanut butter and jelly and
I would get peanut butter and jelly in
my lunch every day and there was this
kid in my grade
Brett Lichtenberg who was allergic to
peanuts and they wouldn't let me bring
peanut butter anymore and I was
devastated but we bought every like
almond but like to try like non peanut
spreads Nutella and I was like I only
want peanut butter I decide I literally
ate chicken fingers and peanut butter
that was it and like 50% of my diet was
immediately cut out because of Brett
Lichtenberg and I was so upset and so
now I'm just like bitter any time I hear
about like the allergy kids winning but
it's they should like it's not their
fault here's the thing I think your two
scenarios are apples and oranges in a
large cafeteria where a person can step
out if they're feeling like they smell
peanuts and they can easily go to the
nurse no you should be about when you
have a kid you don't know you're just
like sitting in a friend's clothes
airplane where you have to do an
emergency landing of someone smell the
peanut okay maybe just no peanuts yeah
so they didn't say anything about peanut
butter and they didn't say anything
about bringing your own they just said
they would stop serving them well that's
just you're an [ __ ] if you bring your
own people but I sell it in like Hudson
News
what if you've tried I'm totally better
and you only like peanut butter and
chicken fingers like the day that they
announced that like my world came
crashing down I remember this literally
one part you know remember in our
kitchen where we grew up there was like
that slide-out pantry and that's where
we kept the mean letter like by the door
and like that was my home I mean it's
very sad and why are so many people are
allergic to peanuts now like whereas 20
years ago they were like allergies
contagious that's what you're like were
there's many people in the age of you're
allergic to peanut butter as they are
now no it was and like now I think kids
if you go to a first grade like so many
kids we should do a poll so many kids
are already in our first grade one kid
was allergic to me a better brother late
summer Ryan Lee I think these brother
yeah they were both allergic genetic I
can't wait to get a text later studies
about this how like people now have so
many more allergies including like
celiac and like yeah all these things
and what is causing it one is it just in
your head
that's just like human evolved 'men to
do out do things like this just like
become more common I don't get it it's
like evolution right I don't know but
we're suffering because of it yeah I
love peanut butter peanut butter isn't
so that's on everything on everything
what's the best way not to eat peanut
butter well when you're not on a diet
just like a regular standard PB&J you
can't go wrong ever agreed hmm
best way to eat peanut butter and not to
be a cliche but really on Oreos are so
good and that was not made up and we
will have sufficient peanut butter and
Oreos at camp toast yeah of course I
would say besides for the standard PB&J
which is always good a great way to mix
it up is we used to have graham crackers
in our house cinnamon graham crackers if
you take a cinnamon graham cracker like
honey Graham just flavor cinnamon and
put peanut butter and jelly on it it's
divine and if you're on a diet and
actually good way to eat peanut butter
and jellies on a rice cake a Quaker one
it's pretty good that's just you or with
a piece of celery which is actually also
good with our eating celery also you
have to get the ratio correct if peanut
butter and jelly because it's 90 percent
peanut butter 10 percent Ellie but that
10 percent Ellie is so important because
then your mouth gets stuck but I
actually come from a place of really
loving jelly so I would do more like
7030 jelly
okay okay but still never do
do you guys know some people are
psychopaths and do like peanut butter on
one side and jelly on the other and then
push together no you get one piece of
bread you do a nice thick layer of
peanut butter and then there is a drop
off of jelly
piece the right on top slice down the
middle maybe get rid of the crust if you
want the crust is fine just as her crust
I like remember Uncrustables those were
disgusting yes so extreme like cutting
it's not like cutting up your crust is
the most labor-intensive treacherous job
for parents like it takes to not like no
one was brining bread crusts and they
know better we take your uncrushable
frozen chemical [ __ ] as opposed to
taking two seconds just to cut off the
crust in its the crust or if you just
don't eat it you just don't eat the
crust totally Wow
people are so easy maybe that's why
Smuckers is going under totally what
others next we have a camp toast any
time we talk about toes it's the only
thing I want to talk about well we're
obviously having s'mores at our
countering campfire challenge you know
it's a funny it'll be funny because the
place the grounds that we're using which
are beautiful are the same grounds that
we went to fat camp on so it'll just be
funny to like go there to eat whatever I
want
Oh totally and that'd be restricted that
anyway but we were crazy but like we
would fill up I'm like Quaker bars Oh
fat cakes
specialty bars now we can have a
Hershey's bar right no you were like
we're gonna have s'mores I'm like that's
not allowed we'll have a low-carb s'more
yeah next story from CNN Money is just
major Tesla is going big in China
Tesla already disrupted the auto
industry now it's changing business in
China too for the first time China will
let a foreign automaker open up shop
without a Chinese company as its partner
Wow that's made with saving up for the
first time China will let a foreign
automaker
open up shop without a Chinese company
as its partner Tesla I think it's just
what Trump's always talking about China
perhaps the trades but Elon Musk played
by Tom Hanks is bringing it over there
Tesla has plans to open a plant in
Shanghai that will one day crank out
500,000 vehicles a year enough to rival
the company's main plant in Fremont
California that's crazy
Tesla said it will be the sole owner of
the factory until now China has always
required foreign companies to enter
joint ventures with domestic come
these Tesla expects to begin
construction in the near future how do I
get that deal because Elon Musk who does
Elon know he was meeting with the
Shanghai Mayor yang Yang after Ted
slowly should deal to build its first
Chinese plane in the city he's just a
man of the world and like I feel like if
Elon came to me and like wanted to do
things differently than I've been doing
them for hundreds of years I would just
spread my legs and let him do it I would
say Elon take the wheel take it from my
hand cuz I can do this on my own
[Music]
Underwood right that's all that's a
popular Christian song the champion from
American Idol and now I'm sorry it's
Carrie Underwood song of course did you
sing it on the roof of course she did
yes she was driving with a fatty on our
way to Cincinnati had a bad leg it's you
know she really you know she does going
home she told stories in her song
jenny/cory time that saved for album
Jenny all his money could never save
Jenny from the devil living in his eye
she's so great she's so great and so is
he unless what you think speaking of
Kim's I don't know if this is a story
because it's probably not but Kim
Zolciak came out with a new song it's
not a story it's that's shocking
it's called wig and I actually had to
subscribe to [ __ ] Apple music just to
get it I was just trying to buy it you
can't buy songs on your phone anymore
did you know that for like a dollar no
you can't I tried to it wouldn't come on
and they took me to Apple music well
maybe she only release it on Apple music
oh maybe it was like sonar whatever I
and I started a one-month free trial
that I'm gonna cancel in 30 days just so
I could listen to it and honestly it's a
banger it sounds really good yeah get
off my wig oh and I put on my Instagram
story and Kim Zolciak responded and you
know she's like my number one Stan and I
don't interact with her at all which is
really sad she doesn't like know where I
am or give a shred of [ __ ] but pretty I
will tell her yeah yeah no but I wrote
her and I see if she responded I wrote
she wrote me back tears like thank you
so much I'm like honestly I love you in
Bri Alex support your family 100% will
teacher her back fresh she wakes up
early yeah totally hmm it's not looking
good nope okay did you read it yet great
question let me check she always seen
[ __ ] sad whatever she has a podcast now
so but I feel like she's now in the
digital space with us and we could
totally get we'll get on her
it's like Oh which company podcast is
number one morning toast what's that Oh
exactly this Yeti exactly that's how it
goes anyways Elon is just changing the
world once again
of course he's changing the world here
on earth and up in space so is he doing
this we could sell Tesla's in China yeah
and so we can produce way more cars than
he is which is exciting for me because I
don't feel like I think I've only been
in a Tesla 100 in Nashville we were in a
Tesla who were in November
well our driver picked us up and it has
that really was a blue like an iPad was
it blue I don't it was night we were it
was that night oh this and the screen
where it's usually like a little GPS was
like a big iPad it was had it nilaam
written all over it
really yeah and so I just hope that this
new China deal brings more Tesla's to
New York City uber drivers if you were
to get a car what kind of car would you
get either a Hummer or a punch buggy
okay but like an actual like let's say
Cup Chuck no siree like you and I if I
were it cuz what can answer the question
you and Zack needed a car like to just
have in the city into like you got to
have in the city like maybe if you like
for your future kids so I take them to
school but for the most part like to
live your life is I know you go to
Jersey Shore this weekend like to go
there like you just into the car like a
regular car what would it be I have kids
not yet but like you're it's soon it's
for the kids yes like it's a life car
okay so I'm not gonna go punch buggy
even though that'd be really easy to
have in the city yeah pickup truck I
would want to pick up shrinkage in New
York City garage and we're like here
park it they'd be like no no like if I
had a pickup truck and I was just ever
feeling like blue or down like I would
just go get my pickup truck I would sit
and I would park it sitting expected
driving of course not and I would just
like play country music and I'm telling
you I would be the happiest person on
earth
so I actually when I was a national man
rented a pickup truck and it really did
lift my spirits like 100 percent in
Dallas Zak's uncle as a pickup truck and
like we it's so weird to be like hey can
we use your car when talking about a car
but we go there just to take the truck
and it's like you really feel something
yeah but like if we were driving that
around the streets of New York where you
can't really there's no open road you're
like stuck in traffic all the time like
it's not as thrilling we were driving
down
Franklin Tennessee with the windows I
mean like you would like you
you can't do that in the city there's
nowhere to drive yeah so if I had to get
just a standard SUV family oh maybe a
minivan just because I loved one okay I
would get a limousine I love a limousine
as well actually I do not love a
limousine because ever since I get
motion sickness there's only one seat I
can have and you always take it yeah
anyways are we done with Elon yeah no
good for him for going transatlantic now
he's the global brand I mean he's
already a universal brand I actually had
heard I had heard that he was bringing
on Sonja Morgan who also has an
international luxury brand just to help
with some marketing that's what I had
heard I heard that as well and you know
it's clearly working because they're
being talked about in the morning toast
every day this week very prestigious but
I love how when we try to expand we go
two ways airplanes and Elon Musk no we
go branding yeah
like business news I love business I
love businesses and I love brand news
like it's so interesting yeah and I love
Elon and what he lands doing for the
show not only what he's doing for China
and Tesla and the world what he does for
this show he elevates us to a level were
untouchable you know like I think it was
like maybe like six months ago where we
got an email from a couple girls who
worked at SpaceX in LA and like their
emails were like at SpaceX comm and they
were like we love your show we're like
we love your boss didn't they say
they're gonna swag yeah we never got it
interesting we never got it but you know
things happen things happen and we're
not getting it because if it was sent
from SpaceX it would be here in a minute
right some maybe there's a drone
dropping off at our houses as we speak
oh my god the berries it would be crazy
okay speaking of China Lamar Odom
announced his plans to move to China
it's just so funny when you say China
like my mind automatically goes to China
with why does yours yeah well I'm
reading it right right it said speaking
of China that would have also been a
fantastic segue except that she's China
right no no but like if I was just like
out to lunch or someone and someone's
like did you hear what happened to China
I'd be like no no something happened to
dream like you know it's confusing it is
another one to add to the list we call
her by her real name Angela Angela Renee
Kardashian yeah actually they were gonna
I read some Angela
honestly as much as Rob as the devil for
bringing that disgusting person into
their Kardashian's I'm so glad he never
fully went through with it like if they
had not married she would be so much
worse because she would have legal
rights to everything sure but having a
baby is it's bad permanent yeah it's
permanent but like from a legal
standpoint like she could have become
Angela Kardashian and she would have
speaking of regretted both marriages
okay
Lamar Odom is ready for a new life
overseas the former NBA star and
ex-husband to Khloe Kardashian announced
innocence deleted Instagram post on
Tuesday that he's packing up and moving
to Shenzhen China quote happy and proud
to announce that I have signed the
global management contract with my new
at 90 plus official family he captioned
the snap of him standing next to it who
are presumably his business partners the
company according to its website hosts
concerts and music festivals and also
manages intellectual property for
entertainers what about our intellectual
property justice for protect at all
costs
some of the celebrity partners already
connected with the company includes
singer Akon and R&B producer and star
Teddy Riley so here's my question
is it a basketball thing no it seems
like an entertainment thing oh that's
good but it's in China yeah I think he
needs to leave the country he's grasping
at straws here for for some work he is
but you know what I have no sympathy for
him none like he not only got a second
chance at life but he's gotten multiple
chances at Kardashian life and he's
blown them all and you know what scram
scram AF and I was watching old episodes
of the Kardashians with when Chloe was
married to him and it's like we've heard
somebody talk about what went on in that
house you know Oh have we how did they
hide it from the cameras because it
doesn't seem like they're Christian has
a producer so whatever Kris Jenner
doesn't want made there's never been
anything on Kardashians that they didn't
want us to see right but like they're
filming in the house Khloe's there
Lamar's there and like they seem fine
well yeah they they have to seem fine
the filming show right put it when
you're like I take DC drugs like it's
not your choice whether you're fine or
not no totally but like when you're also
like professional at doing drugs you
know when a good time to do it and when
a bad time to do it is I guess like when
literally you have a full-time job of
sneaking around and like getting high
like you know how to do it it's true
also I just had a thought
because back to your intellectual
property here's the thing we know that
we have a lot of
is that work free who are who are
snitching on us and here's the thing
I've decided that I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna ride on you I'm not gonna kick you
out all you have to do is put us on your
Instagram yeah like just just one at the
morning show it's like and then we'll
literally forgive you forever or just
like write up something that we said
right like credit us on their Instagram
is big because like a lot of ours you'll
only post about chrissy teigen fine fine
right about us to go write about
literally I know like we scratch your
back we supply tons of information and
content for you scratch ours my tax each
a scratch yet yeah it's time I'm ready
and speaking of time it is time that we
bring out our esteemed guest you know
where you love her her name is Raven
gates she's from the back show she was
unfortunately on next season but
unfortunately for her she went to
Paradise I met the love of her life and
she's also here with her mom which is so
cute you asked a ton of questions on
Instagram and we will get them to her
but we were also watching on the
Facebook and YouTube streams so if you
have any questions for Raven about the
seasons of The Bachelor we got so many
questions at T and Colton make sure to
pop them in the stream and we'll get
them to her we believe that we will be
back in just a minute
you
okay we're back with very we even top
state by the way I'm dying to move Toxie
ever since oh yeah you're so down date
with buddy hates is here we're so
excited that you're here you're so cute
and sweet hey how are you doing what are
you doing in New York I'm here promoting
for a new fragrance for its soap and
glory I've been wearing them since I was
in college and so once I got on The
Bachelor scene they sent me some
freebies and so we're just kind of
working together and I'm really excited
cuz that's like one product like I don't
like to do ads but you know if I need
needed to I would go make around yeah
you got to make it rinse so but with
soap and glory I'm like been using them
for forever so it's like so exciting yet
I'm like a part of it but anyway yes
that's on here and you were so happy
you're here so here's a job that's your
filled week and Alexis so gave us really
good tea so you have a lot to live up to
yeah I have to follow behind and our
first question is there's two things
that I need to interrogate you about me
Rachael Rich's birthday party okay well
my brother Brett collects this was so
unclear about it like I feel like she
was intentionally being unclear okay let
me clear the record about it the big
right was not mad at me okay what do you
matter big rights was not mad at
Christina okay big rights was mad at
everybody else like everybody was oh
this Alexis Jasmine yes Teela hello
Astrid yes and what were they doing it
actually Jasmine wasn't there so a big
Jasmine out what were they doing that
she was mad at okay someone was invited
to the party okay that wasn't supposed
to be there that's what Alexa said and
he this person has friendships
relationships with Alexis and his
boyfriend and Astrid and all this okay
so at one part in the party which
Rachel was very busy I mean all of her
friends were there hostess so it wasn't
just bachelor friends who's like every
all of her friends were there and I
think she just was stressed out from
work she had just gotten in there's this
huge party all of her friends are here
she's trying to be the hostess Brian is
there like trying to be a good boyfriend
or fiancé and
they left at some point but I don't
blame them for leaving but I know a big
Rachel enough not to leave right so
Christina and I stay to come back here
big rich no no girls lot of girls left
Rachel stayin yeah God Rachel stay oh
yeah big mistake that only chance we
have to I mean I see both sides yeah
there I get why they left
but I also I'm like we all know Rachel
well enough that you don't leave her
party well party yeah just a like but
everyone was drunk it was just like you
know one of those things like
miscommunication and drama drugs
miscommunications are very real yeah
it's a real thing so and Rachel is the
talk to like really voice how she's
feeling but then she doesn't want to
hear what you have to say so it was like
say I feel that rage yeah she's like I
know y'all like doing your thing she's
like that was kind of rude but then she
doesn't want to she doesn't even want
you to apologize yes she just wants you
to know that she's here that up me too
cuz no one else I got it about unclear
she's like this guy I'm like yeah okay
thank you for clearing that out here so
welcome so I think you're like you've
become like the spokesperson for Tia now
because you're a very happy relationship
and we love following even Adam on
Instagram its premium content always hey
let me get with his kitchen it looks
really good and I love that but like
you're you're like you're settled now
and now you guys like in the thick of it
and because you brought her on the show
you're like her spokesperson cuz she
can't really talk about what's right
yeah and you got into a very heated
Twitter feud with my mortal enemy back
in America
I know she's really nice I just don't
get a good vibe her and I just know we
would get along yeah like I don't know
her I'm sure she's so nice and cool but
like I just know that if I met her we
would hate each other like she would
hate me too
yeah you just seemed like we couldn't be
more different I was like living for the
team and what pissed me off about the
tea was that she was calling out like
the fact that this was probably
orchestrated because they had dated
before and now they're together in
paradise
and like okay great who cares the whole
show is orchestrated when you're calling
it when you went on a fake show and
we're fake and then calling out someone
else's fakeness like you're not supposed
to talk about that's when I got me
it's like an unsure organ friend like
and she knew that Tia was filming at
this time so she could spot the
hypocrisy of it all was just like much
too much and I was actually at Adams and
I texted out a screenshot of her saying
whatever she said saying how it was
orchestrated and all this stuff and I'm
like but wasn't she
orchestrating a friendship with Becca to
be on the show right because they're not
really friends from what you've said
about her shed a shade so I was like huh
I'm about to say something you better
stop me did you know what you were doing
like how big of a deal it was gonna be
no like it was so dramatic
a news are you kidding they're out of
cycle ah-ah-choo Mountain must do really
well for them yes they will pick up any
crime it was nuts but it was just the
hypocrisy of it all and you know
backstory not everybody has read the
text is that I have read between Becca
and SIA and so after they Becca Martinez
into you yes okay sorry bachelor Beck
bachelor Becca is not Bachelorette Becca
it is not him yeah so I I read a message
between Dylan to Castillo is really
upset of how everything went down on
their show and understandably I told to
it you're gonna have to just deal with
people saying things about how you
talked to Ari and got kind of it looked
like you got Becca kicked off the show
you're gonna have to deal with that
right and but I also saw their messages
between each other like tea apologizing
that cos saying how she felt was a very
mature conversation they hung out like
it was all good and then they went to
filming for parrot like they were
hanging out right and they went to
filming for the reunion or the after the
final rose and Becca would hurt Tia was
already in her room and Becca got on
Jimmy Kimmel and just blasted her and so
then I was like she couldn't take up for
herself in but it's the same thing now
Tia's off to filming she says something
else and like she'll go on podcast and
say everything but then like her and Tia
will talk and they're fine right it's
just like worried what are you
and she intentionally president I can't
respond yeah it's just and that's what
got me she couldn't respond and like if
you're my friend you're my friend I
don't agree with what Tia did where it
is doing or with Colton I don't agree
with that either but don't think I get a
cry agree with her don't be a hypocrite
and don't like say you're going to stop
talking about somebody right and you can
do you need to do so very well I'm so
here forty and Colton you can let you
know yeah the bride's man there's no
like her like having to orchestrate it
because Colton is just like that
wonderful let's see he's so good do
whatever take wait okay I have Colton
into you had sex no because he's still a
virgin you know they think he's lying
about being a virgin no they say in that
book that I'm lying about being a virgin
cuz a sex to jump at a time but I can't
help it by heavy flow and a wide-set
vagina sorry they say that he's lying
about the virgin yeah he's not and
here's the thing I really really like
Colton I think he's wonderful in meeting
him in person he is all gorgeousness and
like he exudes being a good person mhm
it but them - I know - you well enough
they don't mesh oh it's like I get it
like it's a great thought for them to be
together but it's not what she needs and
not what he needs but I love them both
like Adam and Colton talk all the time
I'll talk to Colton every once in a
while like once a week or something and
then of course I thought you see all the
time so who would you want to see him
want to see her with oh okay like from
The Bachelor or maybe a little a celeb
okay I would like to see Tia with
someone let me think
maybe like the grocery store guy
generally because he's like super hot
and that he also has a job right and he
needs someone that's super attractive
yeah she can't do like well cause she's
my pain yes she can't do plain-jane guys
yes though sorry I'm like screwing
Colton I could see him with someone
someone that's really pure at heart and
yet is just as pure as he is also but
just as beautiful - and it's like I
don't know
know who that person is the person
doesn't exist either yeah she's she
doesn't exist right now but maybe she
will come later okay
very fair yeah so you recently moved to
Dallas
yes do you love it with your man I yeah
I love it and it's just I've always
wanted to live in Dallas so it's just
like one of those things I was gonna do
on my own whether I was seeing or
together but like I don't really obsess
about him yeah and I'm like really happy
no he's like he really is you know how
people get on social media and they like
talk about their significant other and
it's like oh all rainbows and
butterflies of course it's not all the
time but like I really do feel
butterflies like talking about him and
it's just like he's like at first it was
so obsessed with me and like now I'm so
obsessed with him and I'm like calling
him from work like when are you coming
go are you home yet like can you come
home early so I'm really happy to be and
isn't it the best that he has a real job
like all these bachelor thoughts are out
here so tea and sleep until noon he got
an offer to do a phablet unbox and I
said this is where I draw the line like
you could probably hurt my family or
whatever and I'd still be with you sorry
mom but you cannot do that bit fun box
yeah I mean I totally totally know what
Peter Krause is the only person who can
do it and me still like yeah and still
be attractive he would lose everything
yeah including me but I totally get what
you're sad yeah so I don't know so are
you gonna bring shop gray suede to
Dallas I would love to go all online
right now I still am in a fleece with my
brick-and-mortar store and Jonesboro so
that has been it kind of an issue but
how much longer is least 30 years Oh Tim
where I can pay like a really big chunk
of money to get out of to get out of it
but I'm like my girls are pretty
self-sufficient so maybe I can just
leave it open I don't know I mean we do
fun there but like the percentage that
we do online it's just like that's you
can sell to the mass isn't right and you
just launch a curve yeah it's really
cute it's it's been going really well
and I've had to have a lot of help
just because everything is so crazy and
it's so hard to keep up with so like it
is literally may just biessing
everything until I figure it out
that's like it is I someone said you
have attained that like healthy I'm like
no it's literally it like me and my best
friend and we're like biessing thing yes
how do we show this show we quantified
late-life is it all turns out very well
it's so comforting to know that everyone
around you is also faking it and then
nobody knows what they're doing that
makes you feel so good but yeah like
hire tons of people and have this big
friend it's just like there's nothing
there it's so yeah I'm like do do you
produce anything like do you to make
money right like if you hire all these
people like and you don't do any of the
work then broidery like do you have
money I said but all the time people
have like three decisions I'm like how
much money are you making to be paying
three people's full tonight
yeah or do people just like you well
enough to work for free yeah waiter they
come from an audience right yes those
people actually do work for free because
when I was an intern at NYU I mean when
I was a student at NYU they have an
internship database and Sonja Morgan's
company advertises there and all of her
interns are anyway your students who get
credit I need that like you can get
credit at working at gray slate like I
will put your ass to work okay like it
is like anyone that steps in if it's my
mom my dad my best friend's anybody I'm
like okay your work up those boxes yeah
so but um you live in Dallas now and so
does Alexis and Rachel right
yeah and disserve and I'll still live
there yes [ __ ] I won't even know
Shelly tried to date your boyfriend
okay bitter because I am okay no I'm not
bitter because she's moved on there was
like some awkwardness between us for a
very very long time but I actually met
her boyfriend we went to the Rangers
game I don't know if you saw where all
of us bachelor people went to the
Rangers game do that see where was I it
was like a few months back but she came
with her boyfriend and like everything
was good like everything was cool but
she's that she like is settled and has
her own group of friends I think she's
just over a Bachelor life and I totally
get that but but you never forget that
she tried to like cuddle with your
boyfriend yeah I'm like there's still
yeah and the couch and my mom even said
she like came to Dallas for the first
time well two atoms for the first time
this weekend or this past week and she
was like this couch is uncomfortable and
I'm like yeah I know
where's the couch in your living room
yeah you must burn it you'll get a free
couch come on yeah
all modern you can get and I'm like and
I tell Adam I'm like we mean we can buy
a couch like you get accounts totally
you can get a different couch like
you've redone your kitchen yeah mr.
moneybags like Bossin and cow I totally
agree get the couch be Sarah's couch I
get it wait a minute Raven coughs I mean
you need a Raven couch so that is so
funny that's amazing thank you for your
honesty yeah totally yeah that's the
couch and let us know what you do I will
send you a picture of it when it's like
exiting out yeah look on the side of the
street leaving it for someone to pick it
up Alexis says she really wants to be a
Dallas housewife would you get married
to Adam and become a Dallas housewife
1000% and Adam would be in it he would
like worse you know how like Peter there
for a minute
like held a peach with Cynthia Atlanta
yeah like everyone's like uh hold the
page because you're in the women drama
at that or piqué piqué Hill that's right
yes
that's Adam gottschalk lately I'm like
oh my god Alexis just called me let me
tell you what she said and he's like
tell me no he would ever like come on
the moon and apologize yeah he would
stand behind me and I'm like I would say
like yeah like you're home and my mom's
laughing cuz you know would you guys
ever get married on television no I
think so too I think it's enough like
for everyone yeah I just like first of
all I don't want to be in like in the
most important day of my life like
exchanging vows because Adam says we
have to write our vows so like
expressing this to him and then cameras
being around and me being distracted
it's so inauthentic yeah yeah I just
that's not for me
well ever since Taylor and Derek broke
up like you two are the last remaining
bathroom behind every time I'm lucky
news post an update I'm like anybody how
gonna be is the most me that's not going
to be do you guys go back to Paradise
this year and like coach yeah I don't
know if we're supposed to say but yes we
have it I hope so further there so yeah
yeah been engaged in paradise I hate
right now maybe oh my god even though
the toasters would have wood I guarantee
yeah probably
what are your thoughts on Ashley and
Jarrod I don't know either of them so I
mean congratulations
that's so funny cuz you were on paradise
with Ashley at some point right no no
never
she was on the season before me so I was
never on the season before that I was
like really never and the one before
either of them in person yeah Wow yeah
they're the two two bachelor alums that
happen because they're coming from like
a previous generation like at the end of
the first generation and you guys are
like you know social media generation
yeah yeah I guess though you had told us
right before we went live that Derek pet
lived in New York yeah and we did not
know that and like I can't believe that
I haven't like intentionally wanted to
know what we should have done is had him
come on with me
I completely agree but now that I know
that he lives here I need everybody we
wouldn't have had a chair and you should
we would have had to sit on his lap
because we're late for you yeah of
course um if you are watching right now
and even instrum please go to Derek
pepsin and say please come on the
morning chose tag us and then I'll DM
him because you know I live for DMing
him we look salacious DM from back of
the day pretty Taylor not pre Ben no
okay okay we have a lot of viewer
questions and they're very good this one
is very pertinent why does your baby
line spell gray differently than gray
suede oh okay so my baby line is with my
best friend who has a daughter her
middle name is great it was felt
differently we use that gray instead of
mine but it's still like linked yeah
exactly
that's so cute such a businesswoman hey
fellow entrepreneur speaking of how do
you stay in such great shape while
working and owning a business and being
in a committed relationship because it's
really bad because Adams read that last
night when it could be for ask me why
she's like what are you gonna say if you
haven't worked it like he's always
trying to get me to go to the gym but
I'm so busy it's like really hard but I
think it's just I mean I had to buy my
boobs so you know I'd have no curves
like I literally looked like
eleven-year-old boy before puberty that
was just like stick straight
I just knit have never had curves of any
con and so now that I've gotten older
like you know you're white shifts or
whatever so I've kind of filled out but
I've just I mean I had about boobs
because I looked like a boy I think my
favorite thing you ever did was
screenshot an email that like InStyle
wrote EULA we have a doctor here who
says your boobs are fake can you confirm
and you literally just green chutni were
like yeah I got them when I was 70 it's
like you yeah she actually ran into that
person at an event and I talked to her
for a very long time I'm sorry oh no but
I just told her it was kind of
disgusting the way she wrote the email
because I'll tell you about my boobs
that's fine but you're a lot but in the
email she was like if you don't tell if
I don't get a response we're still
writing it right I'm like okay well yeah
you know story yeah and now you don't
yeah it was so dumb no that was genius
yeah no that was amazing
do you ever see or still talk to Nick
vile okay
I've seen Nick vile twice and they would
have both been at Coachella okay you are
now the third person Corrine was on the
show Alexis on the show and now you know
we asked tell you Cena caballo they're
like I literally haven't seen him since
my semen season except one time at
Coachella yeah well the first time I
said yeah yeah that's only Tommy's out I
guess and so the not this past Coachella
but to Coachella before he was very very
sweet to me very con and he was with
Vanessa and so she was very condom very
sweet to me too and we talked for a good
maybe hour and a half Wow like just us
three and everyone's like lurking in the
bushes like what are they talking about
but it was literally just like chit chat
and then in like how's your family all
that stuff well this last time where I
was with all the girls from my season at
Coachella he was like yes you know what
I mean wait in that scene on your I
don't think we ever had you on the show
after your season so these are all my
questions from your season yeah when you
and Nick had sex and they made you dance
on the streets of Finland or ever you
were like how much did you want to kill
everyone who made you do that
okay um I thought it was hilarious okay
so like no regrets
great I thought where's Judith I thought
it was hilarious and funny and like my
friends how
one of my friends has me in the snow
doing the angel framed in her mouth like
this and it's just like active circle
area so I didn't care and were you
actually in love with Nick vile the okay
The Bachelor fits you in such a bubble
that you start to develop feelings
because first of all he's the only mate
you're looking at all that time and then
like you know how when your girls get
together and you're like oh that guy's
cute and they think he's really cute and
they got in there and you're like oh
yeah he he's actually really cute so you
go from him feet right not attractive to
oh he's really cleared mentality yeah
that's how it was happening and
progressing but I will tell you this and
I think I'm out of my contract so
hopefully they don't send me a cease and
desist letter but I actually stopped
Chris Harrison before I walked in
because I was like I can't do it I can't
not do it before we watching where to
the airpo yes where I got broken up with
right I was like I just knew right I
knew and so I was like I can't do it he
was like you have a minute I was like oh
my gosh so I just like I was like okay
I'm just gonna throw that thought in the
back of my mind and go did you know it
was Vanessa or do you think it really
might be you I know I really thought it
was me
oh yeah yeah he he would say things to
me like off camera and on camera that
would just give me the validation right
and there was something he mentioned a
ring before and like and I was like and
I told the producers I said if he sends
like someone over here for rings I can't
do it right but like that never airs all
these right but like I meant I hope I'm
out of my contract but it's that's fine
okay I actually didn't those my next
question yes that's when they file I
often think that not most of the girls
don't have sex with guys like I know I
don't think Kayla had sex with Ben
Higgins who Kate Whitman I'm not doing
90 but yeah she didn't know but I think
Jojo and Lauren both did because he had
they both actually asked him I did
feeling you did enough sex and I could
yeah Wow
good thanks for clearing that no I never
asked but I don't wanna pry I'm so glad
you brother
I told my mom you know I'm from the
south parents are devout Christians and
we've live in a small community and so
like when we're at our home town they're
like people circling that had driven
like from Mississippi and see that we're
like driving all over our house and
stuff so like when I came home and all
this had happened I told my mom I was
like you and Dad might be really upset
with me because I talked about orgasms
and like right the church community and
all that stuff so that was a whole
nother and I was like but I didn't even
do it
you know but now that I think about it
you've lived such a life because you
were also on The Bachelor Paradise doll
heard round the world yeah yeah and also
like I think America fell in love with
you when you told us that you beat your
ex-boyfriend with your heels
oh yeah cheating on you yeah and then
like America of course I found him oh
yes okay here's the here's the thing
with that because everyone's like oh you
just went in there and you beat the [ __ ]
out of him with the heel yeah kind of
but he he pried them apart and I was
confronting the girl and maybe hitting
her I had a huge amount of rage and
energy you shouldn't hit them it's not
right what I did but I did it because
there is rage inside my body and I
couldn't help it and I was just so
completely caught off guard because I
was living with him it was my bed I had
no idea who this girl was
anyway that's neither here that makes
the council its look alright yeah see
like when I was confronting her I had
pushed her and he had to grab me and put
me in a headlock right
oh so I reach for what I couldn't it was
a stiletto shoe much like the one I have
want not this one but much like this one
and I just beat him in the head like it
was great you know my thing that I did
I'm when the world obviously figured out
who he was because everyone on the
internet is crazy
yeah did you talk to him like what was
oh yeah yeah I mean like he's still like
talks to me today that's so great Wow
which is very weird because you think
after I humiliated him
never gave me an orgasm hey I've been a
minute ahead with the shoe like he would
hate me but we actually have a okay
decent relationship that's great happy
endings um also this is so interesting
the atom is Jewish yes how you knew this
you ready knew this but we just haven't
like mentioned in in a while I also have
dementia it's like that I could have how
has it been dating a Jewish man they
made that sweater is wears out of my
mouth he here's the best human being so
and it's because you bow he was right
yeah and so I love it I love everything
about it when I went to his mom's house
for the first time I was like okay show
me the bar mitzvah boys I need to see
him in a yarmulke she make you eat
everything on planet Earth okay his
mother was actually Catholic and
converted so when they got divorced she
converted back but she I mean she has
all these memories and was very involved
in the community in California so but
his dad and his dad's new wife are very
devout Jewish people so love it yeah so
I have had like quiche at the house and
of like visiting with the dad and all
this stuff but are there any Jewish
people in Hoxie no no right here here's
what's weird we have I know Muslims I
know
Catholics obviously Christians all these
other and like all these like random off
you know branded religions but I have
never met a Jewish person until I went
to the back Skyrim Wow
exactly Quran in the my three closest
producers were Jewish that's so but
what's so strange about all of this is
my dad is obsessed with you Jewish
people we get along like I said like he
would oh if he knew y'all were Jewish
you would like be like okay tell me
everything bless me not it's like he
would obsessed with Adam yeah yeah and
then we did like our DNA test yeah 20
days yes and at
was 40 48 percent Ashkenazi do it my dad
was like oh my god like he was Zoe I'm
gonna do 23andme and I'm ninety-nine
point nine nine zero esta he's I thought
there was something like some relative
who like lied about marrying a Jewish
person like had kids and it was like a
part of 100% well I found out I'm Asian
I'm African American
yeah I found out I thought I was Native
American I'm I'm every woman are
everyone you are oh my god you're so
funny and I just like sitting here
talking generally remembering things
that you did on TV and like they're like
you never like had a bad moment on TV
which is such an accomplishment and then
people is like so many people go on The
Bachelor and then like they have to live
with the shame for a while and then it
goes over and then they have like a
couple hundred thousand in certain
powers and it's okay
but like do you have a million you have
you're crazy Adam I think that nuts like
who wants to follow me no you are just
content nice into accounts actually yeah
no you just like you got out clean and
I'd like wash your hands of it and like
you know that you have a full life yeah
after a matter how great can say that me
yeah yeah I mean the only like hiccup I
had was my fault with Christina and on
the beach last season and that was what
she's being overseen she was being so
the downer I wanted to kill her I know
I'm that's how I felt too yeah
oh my last question for you is how did
you maintain your hair in Paradise
because we like similar long hair and
all I can think about is when I watch
Paradise it's like what I would do with
my hair because I can't put my hair up
yeah and I certainly can't leave it down
I had like this spritz Brad put in it
but like at the like two days in I was
like no I'm not doing this anymore and I
was really really sick on paradise I was
getting three shots in my butt a day
while I was in Paradise my my skin had
broken out because I was having really
really high fevers like it was almost
sent to the Mexican hospital I was like
no I would rather die here in the bed
because I'm scared they almost like the
the nurse put a needle in me and it like
had glass shards in it and Daniel Maltby
was like no no she's a nurse and she was
like I will give her the shot so Daniel
Mont they actually gave me shots in my
rear end every day on pair
so nice so like I was not about to trust
their meta brain when they like didn't
even know how to give a shot I'd rather
just die here what were you so glad you
did it we're so glad you did there and
where can people keep up with Raven
gates Adam gray suede where where's the
best place to follow you
Raven Nicole gates is my ig and shop
gray suede is my stores IG and we just
launched curvy so all shapes and sizes
games to come shop and yeah it's really
cute and I love following along and
thank you for being here
thanks for being an open book and of
course if you enjoyed anything that you
watched here because we know you steal
from our show feel free to write it up
and credit the morning toast everyone
loves our show you can too it's okay
it's an a pleasure hanging out with
everyone this is the morning toast we're
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time we're back tomorrow presale
for my show Boston ends today so if
you're a patreon member make sure to
pick up a ticket and then they go self
live on sale for everyone else on Friday
bye bye please
you